Tim hello I've been Steven I have a
question about tactical execution
against a vision a strong vision sets
directions and enables the whole
business to focus on outcomes but what
are your top three recommendations for
creating the vision that has high
tactical value in other words a vision
that everyone knows what to do with and
how to execute income with the vision
it's really important to have a clear
surround result an outcome what is it
you know your your mission is about
launched in and helping millions of
entrepreneurs you know sages vision
would be to launch the next 10 million
businesses and create the foundation for
millionaires to go and help their
communities creep yuge prosperity and
job creation so the clarity around that
mission that rallying cry it is really
important and it has to be end result
bounce so you know what are we going to
do by 2020 and how we going to change
the world and how we're going and then I
think you need to bring it down some
very tactical things in terms of getting
back to what we talked about before it's
not about the old world it's not about
think they will do it's about to first
so it's the kind of thing we're going to
do tomorrow to achieve that what we're
going to do next week what are we gonna
cheat and get really tactical really
focused and then I do things for it in
porn this business that a business is
fully integrated now it's not
marketing's in that junk it's not an
afterthought it's right at the arm the
business and how do you think about
being where the audience is and being
part of the conversation throughout and
what's that journey look like so simply
through its free things one is have a
big vision big rallying cry know where
the journey is going to take you number
to kind of be really clear about what
the milestones and the steps are there
and then number three is just get on and
do it you know to crack on and do feel
seemed engaged be part of the
conversation my perspective inc is to
add a little bit on that is i would be
attached to what you're trying to do but
not how you're gonna do it how changes a
lot right if you have a clear vision so
i want to help entrepreneurs right i
believe when i sir no I have a billion
entrepreneurs that's our big you know
what what I'm all about that influences
down to a tactical level because
anything that I do has to have big scale
value right so doing one-on-one meetings
probably not doing that anymore unless
that person has an ability to go out and
reach millions of people right so I'm
doing much more in the public eye when
I'm directing my team right somebody
helping me with my youtube videos or
somebody helping me on my social
accounts somebody help me with my
website having that big vision helps
align them for what we all want to do
but I'm not locking them into how to do
it I want them to be creative I don't
want to just give them always here's
what you have to do because then you we
work with a bunch of task managers
instead of people who can actually
projects and so your vision in my mind
helps you create the big picture where
you want to go but then when you drill
down it can give you ideas and I see it
more as the as the lens through which
you see the world as if I'm going to
make this next Instagram post is this
believe or not is this YouTube video
believe or not does it tie into our
mission or not but then not restricting
people to say you can only do this you
can only do these three things because
there's probably a lot of things that if
you can unlock the creativity of the
people on your team around the mission
of the all understand then they're going
to surprise you with a bunch of amazing
initiatives that you would have never
pumped with yourself because hopefully
they're better than you are the skills
that they know and that's why you
brought them on the first end coz you
know this vision is hallucination with X
so to your point evan is all about
course correction you know it works of
what I would say is on a sunday night
you know you're probably catching up on
the paperwork from the last sort of
staff but also just combat like 30
minutes to reflect almost really gone
well this week what would really really
well actually what didn't go so well we
r we going to change next week how
energetic just an example I hadn't met
Evan and my life was a lot for 18 months
ago now ever Nani's business plan
probably never knew that existed and we
got together and we thought actually
let's have some fun together and that's
actually we've got such alignment
between our mission and our purpose and
sense of purpose we want to change the
world so why don't we do something
together we just started why don't we
just do you know a Google
bound together and obviously we love to
really probably you get that we really
enjoy it because it's it's all about
seven new guys make it a difference and
the supportive billion entrepreneurs is
awesome but also hopefully we're
providing to brag book every time we do
one of these ever my kind of reconnect
what what's the big issue out there for
the next one what we do better how could
we serve you as an audience better we
never stop learning you know we're
always kind of at the end of it beat
ourselves up hopefully we do a better
job to you guys and when they were done
on that journey so it just just shows
you this is more of an execution get it
on with stuff and then stay and truly
envision being a company with a heart
and just pursuing your passion I love it
somebody at somebody wrote bromance in
the comments there